one of the best at the wide receiver
position in the business
courtesy of cal berkeley and the los
angeles chargers keenan allen
pro bowl wide receiver how are you doing
keenan allen
i'm doing great i'm doing great i'm
doing fine did i see you tweeting about
durant last night are you a nets fan or
a durant fan what do we what do we got
here
i am a durant and kyrie fan and i'm
actually a james harden fan so
yeah i'm a nets fan yeah but don't you
think that's a super team and they're
kind of
uh you're definitely a super team but
who cares
huh teaming up that's not a pro you know
you don't you don't care about that that
they're just teaming up i mean i
wouldn't care about but
what are we gonna do about it cry about
it or what you gonna do
you're gonna cry about it you can't do
nothing about it huh
that's a point
huh so why do you like those guys where
did that come from at all three of them
and they all happened a bunch of
in their own ways um i'm actually the
kyrie irving and the james harden of
football so
those those are my guys pretty sure how
are you and then
kd is just the best so when you're
you are you saying you're the hardener
football because you get fouled a lot is
that what you're saying
uh because he's the best iso guy
one-on-one you can't
can't stop him you know mm-hmm
i saw it okay and then 13 he's got a
beard
okay so um herbert is the what uh of the
nba who's the who's the justin herbert
at the end
that's joking
it's an easy call the mvp
huh mvp okay but
um is it does he have any serbian roots
i don't think herbert he's just straight
from
nah no okay that'd be tough um um he's
like a uh
i don't know okay i like it i like it
so how are things there in in with the
chargers
because uh oh good man so good um
just happy with the coaching staff the
way that they restructured the whole
thing i feel good about everybody
um you know the the atmosphere was great
in otas mini camp
uh and then we ending the mini cam going
off
to the off season and feel good about
everything so what's what's different
what's the difference can you walk me
through with the differences
the confidence and the way that they
talk in the way that they coach to us
um i think it's more friendly it's more
player friendly and um
i just you know i think we have a better
uh what is it called a
organized situation no kidding so
um what what do you what do you like
about like can you give me an example of
like when
when you heard something you're like
okay i get this and i like it
can you give me an example of that
keenan allen i'm um
i couldn't give you a pinpoint example
but every time brandon staley
talks i'm all live
he has my attention he has my energy uh
you know just the way he talks like i
say that his charisma and the way he
comes off
his very leader leader-like and uh you
know i love
no kidding i love that because i i've
got that vibe
from him too that you know um certainly
when he was with the rams i was hearing
that
the defensive coordinator uh had
quite um a presence about him
and then when the chargers hire him
after just one year as being the dc for
the
for the rams it did raise a few eyebrows
but you say he's ready for this
oh no yeah yeah he's legit
you know he was a former quarterback too
right yeah you could tell
he's a defensive coordinator for a
reason
he knows the offense okay so what do you
mean you could tell like you you could
see that he's got
uh a quarterback one of those guys he's
not um he's not stubborn within his
within his play call he understands what
can be beat within within his system
and he and he knows how to stop it
because he knows the author
okay keenan allen here on the rich eisen
show what about your quarterback
the the the phrase unicorn gets thrown
around i've thrown it around too based
on what i've seen him
what what about him keenan i was like
the perfect phrase you could use unicorn
um savage man i can't wait to see him
grow can't wait to see his growth um
i've been saying it probably for the
last three weeks now uh
i don't he still doesn't know what he's
doing you know he's literally just
lining up and playing football and being
just
urban that's the beauty of it and once
he has that knowledge
and that uh experience of being behind
one side to see so when you say
okay because i know if it's a certain
phrase that you might use
that he doesn't know what he's doing
it's just that he's green
yeah no no um uh so okay so so
i think pat my home said it uh like his
first couple of years of playing he was
just out there playing throw a dime
and then once he was able to learn what
was actually going on seeing coverage
before the snap
understanding what's going on you know
what i'm saying it's just different once
you got the experience and you know what
you're looking for
but he he because he definitely strikes
me as somebody who's
got all of it like literally every last
ounce of whatever the hell it is
he's got it right he's got it was there
a moment last year when you
you realized that yourself keenan last
year
uh yeah the first drive
kc game first drive yeah right because
what was that you knew it right away
what was that from your perspective to
learn what was going on and hey justin's
gonna start today
what about that uh well um we hadn't
i don't think i've ever caught a passing
justin going into that game
uh let alone here i'm talking to huddle
right
so we just we knew it was going to be
different but we knew he was good we
knew we could throw the ball
right you know so and it's the
confidence and the composure that he was
able to
come in the game with and just you know
rally and go down there and score on his
first drive it was just pretty exciting
exactly i remember thinking that i'm
like wait a minute why is he starting
the game
and then i'm like okay i'll buy let me
see what this kid's all about and then
he
scored then you guys scored the first
time down i'm like oh
okay you know and i'm just sitting on
the couch watching that i'm wondering
what it's like to be a pro bowl receiver
in a situation like that
yeah yeah yeah it was for me it was
tough because i'm used to you know phil
you don't use the tie rod you know we
know exactly what we want right
when we line up i know what i want to
get to i know exactly what i want i know
i know what our guys want
it's hot like that oh right
but every everything after that was
dying it was
that's just about composure and being
able to rally and just understanding
yourself and being confident about
you know the work you put in a few
minutes here with keenan allen here on
the rich eisen show okay
keenan are we overlooking the chargers
let's just put it out there
are we overlooking uh me in the media
well you guys are fish
he'll overlook everything about the
charges don't we
who's we the media
well because the reason why i bring it
up is we all you know you know uh
kansas city has won the last two afc
championship games
and you know there's word that rogers
might be knocking on the the broncos
door or one
in on on on this smoke that is the afc
west
um but the tr and that and the chargers
are sharing a home with a team that got
matthew stafford and that's definitely
the mind's eye of everybody
um are you being overlooked let's take
the wii
out of it are you being did you put it
like that yeah i think so
think so but i mean like you say uh you
got kansas city super bowl team
um afc championship back to back so i
mean we obviously got to beat them if we
want to
talk about anything about being
respectable how far can you go do you
think then
oh i mean skies is always the limit it's
off-season so 16-0
17 and those always by the way i like
that you uh
i have to get used to that too 17 and
and all
right um all right so before i let you
go uh keane and alan uh when i saw you
on the golf course the other day were
you coming off a birdie how many birds
like what is your golf game
it was actually my best day of golf that
day oh boy she got a
shot at 87. i had a rally apart i had
about four par
streak i don't think i had any birdies i
missed probably seven birdie bucks
typical that's me you know i'm saying
i'm not the best putter right
i'm not your guy for putt too young i
just think it's my my
my experience again i'm too young i
ain't seen enough greens yet
well plus you know keenan uh the greens
and the course that you were playing
that day
is as top shelf as it gets in the
country not just los angeles the
absolute
first time there too oh keenan yeah it
was tough
so um so you 87 that's an excellent
round
um who's the best stick uh in in the nfl
what do you got for me who's the best
the best player
best stick best golf uh what do you got
in the nfl right now
yes um would you take who do you know
if i had to pick somebody i'm sticking
with my guy the unicorn herbert
he's he's good in golf the guy's a
savage
he's good in golf too yeah yeah he shot
it the first time i played with him he
shot a 77. come on
it was real humble you know
[Laughter]
yeah okay all right he's good he's good
okay and so um and uh so he's the best
on the chargers then
okay are you the best in the wide
receiver room i'm definitely the best in
the wide receiver
okay we'll take that but money badge and
herbert did just whoop me a little bit
at monarch the other day so
okay i won't speak too much on my game
okay keenan there's still time
i appreciate the time i appreciate the
call let's do this again let's do this
down the line
thanks for the uh thanks for the minutes
you be well all right i appreciate it
of course always that's keenan allen hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here